[Musik]
spielplan änderung der name ist wirklich
programm geworden für unseren theater
abend eigentlich hätte das eine große
publikumsveranstaltung mit über 1000
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern werden
sollen jetzt wird es ein fulminanter
drehtag heute morgen im radio war noch
die rede von einer weltkriegsbombe die
hier in der nähe entschärft werden soll
nur das hätte uns jetzt wirklich noch
aufgehalten wir wollen spielen wir
wollen unbedingt auf die bühne und das
machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was mich wirklich empört ist die
kategorisierung der kultur als
freizeitgestaltung diesen menschen das
entscheiden können noch nie mit einem
schauspieler einem sänger einem
regisseur geredet haben für die ist
spielen die die existenz von der man mir
so viel erzählt hat die männer die man
mir an preis wie man mich lässt mit der
zeit und den veränderungen man
eigentlich immer wie sicherer und wie
wichtiger wurde das ganze projekt und
das war total relevant dass das jetzt
heute stattfindet und das war total
schön weil sich plötzlich auch sowas
eingelöst hat was jetzt über ein jahr
geplant wurde aber was sie sind noch
jung
sie müssten sich ein 10 20 jahre
wenigstens bei uns aus bis das sie
lernten wo wir es allen anderen nationen
in der ganzen welt zuvor getan was bei
mir unbehagen auslöst ist die tatsache
dass im diskurs die kunst so relativ
umstandslos dem in einer solchen
krisensituation überflüssigen oder jetzt
mal für eine weile außer kraft zu setzen
freizeitvergnügen subsumiert wird und da
sage ich mal wenn man sagt der
gottesdienst ist ein ort oder
religionsausübung ist ein ort der
sinnsuche der der individuellen
bearbeitung auch von krisensituationen
da trifft das zumindest für die kunst
auch zu
[Musik]
23 uhr
die lange nacht der vergessenen stücke
respekt es war eine lange reise die wir
hier hinter uns jetzt haben mit vielen
verschiedenen preise änderungen und vi
änderungen ich ende habe ich noch die
hat ja hier angefangen die reise im
august an einem heißen sommertag dass
die schalotte gesagt dass das die würde
für dich mit politik zu beschäftigen
einfach eine höhere ist als film oder in
der serie hat sich das im letzten halben
jahr in die ändert ja ich muss schon
sagen das hat sich sehr verändert welt
durch diese unmöglichkeit überhaupt ins
theater zu gehen ist meine sehnsucht
danach total gewachsen und auch nach so
einem gemeinschaftserlebnis was man eben
bei einer netflix ihre oder einem film
nicht hat wenn man zu hause alleine
sitzt und ich sehne mich danach wieder
ins theater zu gehen mit menschen sich
zu begegnen und so etwas zusammen zu
erleben
ja diese sehnsucht die haben wir glaube
ich alle kämpfen wird es doch eine
spezifische sehnsucht wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere da hinten standest du
sagtest du wärst auf der suche nach
anderen identitäten
identifikationsmöglichkeiten bei dem
blick in diese vergessene stücke hast du
das wenn wir jetzt heute hier ein paar
auf der bühne gesehen das hat sich da
was erfüllt von dieser sehen so von
diesem wunsch ja absolut dieses
bedürfnis nach identifikationen wurde
total erfüllt allein durch die vielfalt
der schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
charakterköpfe und verschiedenen rollen
die an diesem abend an diesem tag
zusammengekommen
und diese das hat diese nacht so
besonders gemacht und ja ich denke für
mich hat sich auch noch einmal mehr
gezeigt dass sich das theater einfach
brauche und dass ich hoffe dass der
locker und so schnell wie nötig wobei es
in dem theater im osten
sechs monate später wir sind immer noch
auf abstand aber eine neue sonne geht
auf es gibt wieder hoffnung für das
theater und diese hoffnung symbolisiert
das hier freiluftbühnen wir sind hier
vor dem deutschen theater in berlin ihr
wird gerade aufgebaut gleich fängt die
probe an und in der luft liegt einfach
das gefühl von es geht wieder los das
theater beginnt auf 9 von 9 und eine
wirkliche spielplanänderungen liegt
jetzt in der luft deswegen haben uns
dazu entschieden noch mal eine zweite
staffel zu drehen charlotte du bist
wieder mit dabei welches stück hast du
ja diesmal ausgesucht ich habe mich
beschäftigt mit dem stück sei dann ab
halb von lord byron das hat der
schauspieler fabian hinrichs für die
spielplanänderungen ausgesucht und ist
ein ganz tolles stück das ganz viel hat
was relevant für heute ist warum weil
dieser könig sei dann ab einen
unglaublich aufgeklärt herrmann ist er
will keine kriege führen er möchte nicht
erobern
und er ist aber auch ein hedonist ein
genießer des schönen lebens ein
pazifistischer hedonist mit wem hast du
über diese figur gesprochen
ich habe gesprochen mit dem volksbund
dramaturgen carl hegemann der auch viel
mit fabian hinrichs zusammengearbeitet
hat und der hat mich in diesem
verrückten kosmos des stücks eingeführt
sehr gut
das ist die eine folge die andere
handelt von einem wahnsinnigen
eifersuchts drama der stärkere von der
norwegischen dramatischen tagen die
schule könnte man sich dieses stück hier
im freilufttheater vorstellen absolut
des stückes einen sommer viel es geht um
liebe und leidenschaft sehnsucht und
eifersucht und die autorin seziert in
dem stück die konflikte eines paares
aufseher psychologische weise
du hast über dieses stück mit dem sohn
von willy brandt gesprochen wie kommt
man darauf genau mit lars brandt der hat
für die frankfurter buchmesse 2009 10
eine übersetzung sämtlicher werke von
dagny tool vorgelegt und das der experte
in deutschland für die norwegisch
autoren ein pazifistischer hedonist ein
eifersuchtsdrama und zuletzt in meiner
folge geht es um ein initial werk der
moderne worries mate links interieur
hand
vom fund der leiche einer jungen frau
und zwei männer die sich nicht trauen
diesen fund der familie mitzuteilen sie
stehen das ganze stück über vor einer
fenster fassade und reden darüber was es
bedeutet diese nachricht jetzt zu
überbringen oder eben nicht zu
überbringen
das habe ich zum anlass genommen das
ganze stück über das motiv des fensters
zu erzählen und das als gegenstand ernst
zu nehmen als lebendigen gegenstand wenn
man so will
ich spreche mit einem glasermeister ich
spreche mit einem glasreiniger und ich
beschäftige hinterfragen was das fenster
eigentlich über die moderne aus sagt
drei folgen dreimal spielplanänderungen
wir freuen uns sehr sie jetzt nochmal
mitzunehmen auf diese reise ins theater
und sagen vorhang auf
[Musik]